how are you and first of all tell me
about this dress real quick this is
right or tea
[Music]
oh the
the customer
what does it mean to be here and be
recognized tonight and be one of the new
voices that everyone looks at I know
[Music]
um I feel like fruitful blessed
extremely blessed to be a part of
something so big especially my first
year really in the industry so I'm just
blessed and excited all the way that's
your daughter right there how proud how
proud are you of her I am very proud
what extremely proud
what would it mean to have a Grammy for
you what would that mean
I I'm gonna pass
no come on I'ma cry what does it mean to
see her walking to Grammy's red carpet
unbelievable
yeah but you know I'm all into it I love
it and also when you make music that
becomes an Anthem what is that like how
how strange is that where everywhere you
go in my kitchen my child look out the
kitchen window and there's my son and
his boys lifting weights and there he
screaming oh it's I it feels good I feel
blessed
come on it's more than that to be a name
that's on the tip of everybody
um this time I always wanted to do and I
didn't know it was gonna come this fast
so like I thought I feel blessed I feel
highly favorable you know my middle name
Hallelujah so I'm highly favorable
y'all don't fly yeah yeah
all right good luck tonight because I
mean this could be this is a big night
thank you so much we're gonna turn over
oh yeah come on I'll be backstage as
soon as you come off okay if it's my
first song when I work out every day is
what gives you are you okay
[Music]
enjoy this night